♪ [music] ♪
So it's been a long journey,
but we're at the end of the journey.
Let's review all of the stuff we've
learned, hopefully, during the course
of these last 35 sessions.
So as you start thinking about lessons
learned over the last few weeks,
here are a few that I've learned and
perhaps you might share some of
these conclusions and perhaps not.
The first is as I've talked about Disney
and I've used all of these numbers,
notice how few facts there are and how
many opinions. Even numbers that you take
as facts, accounting earnings from
last year are really opinions.
Lots of opinions drive our analysis.
The second is the real world is a
messy place. Numbers don't end with three
zeros. Things can change all the time.
Third, we've used a lot of models along
the way, but I hope you recognize that
these models are just tools. Many of
them make assumptions and you need
to be aware of those assumptions when
you use those models. And finally,
everything changes every day.
Just when you think you're done,
new things come at you.
That's the reality of corporate finance,
and you have to get used to it.
So let's summarize the 10 lessons that I
hope you've taken out of this class.
The first is we started with the notion
of corporate governance,
but if you boil it down to basics,
we were talking about conflicts of
interests. There are lots of different
entities in a modern public corporation,
and that they're not all pulling in the
same direction. In fact, broadly speaking,
there are at least four groups you got
to keep happy in a company,
and each has its own interests.
The first are stockholders who want to
maximize the value of their shares and get
the highest returns they can.
The second are bondholders who want
to protect their money and make sure that
they get paid their interest payments.
The third are managers who might want to
maximize their compensation and protect
their jobs. And finally, the society,
kind of hanging out there.
And if it's a publicly traded company of a
fifth group, investors, who are making
their best judgments in the company.
It should come as no surprise then that
sometimes when you see decisions made by
a company, they're made to advance the
interests of one group at the expense
of another, and that is at the heart
of corporate governance.
Not everyone will agree on every decision
being the best decision from their
interests. Second, we talked about how
to measure risk, and if there's one broad
lesson that I hope you got out of this is
when you look at the risk in a company,
it depends on who's looking at the risk.
In fact, with publicly traded companies,
we introduce the notion of a
marginal investor, the investor
at the margin who sets prices.
And that marginal investor, we said,
needs to meet two criteria.
One, he or she needs to own a lot
of shares and trade those shares.
Well, based on that assumption,
with most companies especially if they're
large to mid-cap companies,
you can assume that the marginal
investor's probably some kind of
institution. Very few individuals have the
amount of money that will allow them
to be marginal investors. So what?
You might ask. If that institutional
investor, a mutual fund, a pension fund,
is diversified, the way you measure risk
in a company changes forever.
The risk we bring into the cost of equity
for publicly traded companies reflects
that assumption. The only risk we bring in
to the cost of equity is the risk you
cannot diversify away because we assume
the marginal investor being diversified is
going to get rid of the rest over their
portfolio. Third, we measured that risk
with a beta, and that beta, of course,
captures the risk that you cannot
diversify it away. But once you start
thinking about how to measure the risk,
think about all the decisions
that go into your cost of equity.
The first is the choice you make about
what currency you do the analysis in.
We talked about picking high inflation
versus low inflation currencies,
but more importantly,
we said be consistent.
Once you pick a currency,
everything has to be done based
on that currency. In fact,
if you break the cost of equity
down into its components,
each piece plays a role.
Your choice of currency drives your
risk-free rate, and that risk-free rate is
embedded in it and expected inflation
which you should also bring into your
cash flows. Your beta reflects the
business or businesses you're in,
and we talked about bottom-up betas being
much better choices than regression betas.
That beta also reflects choices you make
as a company as to what kind of business
you're in, what your fixed costs are,
and how much debt you carry. And finally,
the equity risk premium reflects where you
do business. If you are a developed market
company but you operate in a lot of
emerging markets, it is my job to make
sure your risk premium carries that
effect. See, risk-free rate reflects the
currency you do the analysis in.
Your beta reflects the businesses
you're in, your equity risk premium
reflects where you do business.
When we talked about cost of capital,
we move past the cost of equity
by bringing the cost of debt.
And let me restate again what the
cost of debt and the cost of capital
is supposed to measure.
It's a cost of borrowing money long-term
today. Key words are long-term and today.
So to get to a cost of debt,
we start with the same risk-free rate
from which we start our cost of equity,
but we add a default spread in sort
of beta and in equity risk premium.
The default spread measures your credit
risk as a company, and to the extent that
the tax code is tilted towards debt,
we bring it into the cost of capital.
That cost of capital helps us assess the
quality of investments. In fact,
there are two ways you can answer
the question, "Are my investments good
investments?" One is to where your equity
had and focus on just equity investors.
What does that mean?
You look at the net income you make
on the project, and you look at the equity
invested in the project,
you come up with a return in equity.
You compare the return in equity to the
cost of equity, you have a measure of the
quality of your investments from
an equity investor's standpoint.
You could look at cash flows to equity,
discounted the cost of equity
come up with a value,
a net present value based on equity
investors in the project.
You could also look at the same projects
from the perspective of the entire
company. What does that mean?
You measure your earnings as after-tax
operating income. You measure what you've
invested as invested capital:
book equity plus debt minus cash.
You return an invested capital that
you get out of those two numbers,
you compare to the cost of capital.
Alternatively, you can focus
on cash flows: cash flows to the entire
business discounted back to the cost
of capital. So you can measure the quality
of your investments either from the
perspective of just the equity investors
in the business, the entire business,
and done right, you should get roughly the
same conclusions. So let's summarize the
lessons we've drawn so far.
The first is if you look at a
modern corporation, it's a web of
conflicts of interest and you have
to figure out whose interests are
being served when you look at a
particular decision. Second,
when you think about risk,
it's not how much risk you and I see in
investment that drives its cost of equity,
it's what the marginal investors see in
that. Third, to convert that measure
of risk into a cost of equity,
you need a risk-free rate and an equity
risk premium. That risk-free rate would
reflect the currency you're working in.
Your equity risk premium will reflect
where your company does business.
And fourth, to make a judgment
on the quality of your projects,
decide whether you're looking at those
projects as an equity investor or from the
perspective of the entire business.
We'll talk about the
remaining principles next.
♪ [music] ♪